restaurant business has just released
the 100 places that made the most money
last year and the best in las vegas
money-wise anyway
well it's the top of the world
restaurant over at the strat
raked in more than 25 million dollars in
sales this is last year of course things
have changed
and served up nearly 250 000 meals
sherry wow who
knew beautiful spot well here's a quick
look at some of the others on the list
joe's seafood prime steak and stone crab
they are yummy
bizarre meat by jose andres and
southwest steakhouse
at the wynn also monami gabby at the
paris of one of my faves
and the list continues with lavo at the
venetian
ultra prime italian
and prime steakhouse at the bellagio as
well as del monaco steakhouse at the
venetian
and carmine's over at caesars in the
forum shop
some yummy spots nate all right here are
the last two on the list from las vegas
how about
beauty and essex over at the cosmo and
from the link there's virgil's
real barbecue right there at the bottom
100 but they made the top 100 list for
the first time 11.4 million dollars in
sales and boy that's a lot of food that
went down again these were all numbers
from last year is that right
yes yeah so 2019 obviously pre pandemic
we're talking about here but just
we all know that we have a lot of
restaurants in las vegas a lot of very
good restaurants in las vegas and
this is just putting a little dollar
figure attached to that